el núcleo filo es un amante de núcleos
si se acuerdan de etimología cuando
tenemos la palabra filo
eso significa amante por ejemplo un
bibliófilo es alguien que ama los libros
alguien que es atraído por los libros
así que un núcleo filo es algo que será
atraído por núcleos y como un núcleo
está cargado positivamente por todos los
protones algo que el núcleo ama algo que
es atraído a esa carga positiva debe
tener una carga negativa un núcleo filo
puede tener una carga formal
completamente negativa o una carga
parcial negativa o puede ser solamente
una región de alta densidad electrónica
como un par de electrones libres o un
enlace pin entonces los núcleos y los
entre mayor densidad electrónica son
atraídos a cosas cargadas positivamente
todo lo contrario con un electro filo
es un amante de electrones como los
electrones están cargados negativamente
algo que es atraído por lo negativo debe
estar cargado positivamente porque las
cargas opuestas se atraen
entonces los electro filos pueden tener
una carga formal completamente positiva
o tener una carga parcial positiva esas
son las regiones de baja densidad
electrónica los electrones se moverán de
regiones de alta densidad electrónica
donde claro hay un núcleo filo a
regiones de baja densidad electrónica en
donde están los electro filos porque las
cargas opuestas se atraen y esa es la
idea de la ley de coulón en física
dibujemos un par de moléculas por aquí
veamos si podemos clasificarlas como
núcleo filos o electro filos empecemos
con el año tóxico se ve así y está
cargado negativamente que es un núcleo
filo o un electro filo bueno el año net
óxido está cargado negativamente por lo
que se sentirá atraído a lo que esté
cargado positivamente ama los núcleos
entonces en un mecanismo de química
orgánica será un núcleo filo reaccionará
como un núcleo filo una molécula muy
similar es el etanol dibujemos el etanol
por aquí
vamos a ver pensemos en la diferencia de
electro negatividad que existe entre el
oxígeno y el hidrógeno qué pasará con
estos dos electrones de este enlace
bueno como el oxígeno es más electro
negativo jalar a los electrones lo más
cerca de él así que tiene una carga
parcial negativa y como la densidad
electrónica
deja el hidrógeno el hidrógeno termina
con una carga parcial positiva entonces
ahora tenemos una molécula que tiene una
carga parcial negativa en el oxígeno
este oxígeno ama los núcleos en un
mecanismo el oxígeno puede actuar como
un núcleo filo y además tiene pares de
electrones libres que son regiones de
alta densidad electrónica la porción
negativa de esta molécula también puede
actuar como un núcleo filo en el
mecanismo así que tenemos dos núcleos
filos diferentes
de estos núcleos y los es más fuerte
bueno es lógico que el más fuerte será
aquel que se sienta más atraído a una
carga positiva por lo tanto es el que
sea más negativo la molécula del primer
ejemplo tiene una carga completamente
negativa una carga formal negativa y en
el segundo ejemplo sólo tenemos una
carga parcial negativa por lo tanto el
año neta óxido será un núcleo filo más
fuerte que el etanol porque tiene una
carga formal negativa así de simple
dibujemos otras moléculas veamos como
podemos clasificarlas aquí tenemos dos
carbonos y luego un cloro por acá le
pondré sus pares de electrones libres
si nos concentramos en este carbono este
carbono que está unido al cloro pensemos
en la diferencia de electrón negatividad
sabemos que el cloro al ser un halógeno
es más electro negativo que el carbono
entonces los dos electrones que están en
este enlace entre el carbono y el cloro
serán colados hacia el cloro dándole una
carga parcial negativa y como esos
electrones se mueven lejos de este
carbono terminará con una carga parcial
positiva si algo tiene una carga parcial
positiva entonces será atraído a algo
que esté cargado negativamente así que
este carbono será un electro filo
podemos decir que este carbono actuará
como un electro filo si hacemos
reaccionar el año net óxido con esta
molécula el cloruro de tilo tiene un
carbono con una carga parcial positiva
actuará como un electro filo
electrones y el núcleo filo tiene los
electrones que le puede dar al electro
filo el oxígeno está cargado
negativamente es atraído a cosas que
estén cargadas positivamente entonces
este oxígeno se sentirá atraído al
carbono que está cargado positivamente
este par de electrones atacará al
carbono atacar esa es la palabra que se
usa en química orgánica para esto en un
mecanismo entonces las cargas negativas
son atraídas por las cargas positivas
esa es la ley de coulón y esta ley
depende de la distancia entre más cerca
estén dos moléculas en una solución más
atraído se sentirá el núcleo filo a
nuestro electro filo la carga negativa
atacará a la carga positiva y si
estuviéramos haciendo el mecanismo estos
electrones tendrían que irse con el
cloro pero no entraremos mucho en los
mecanismos todavía por ahora el objetivo
es ir
núcleos filos electro filos y entender
como las cargas opuestas se atraen
dibujemos otro electro filo otro electro
filo podría ser un carbono unido a tres
carbonos y no hay ningún hidrógeno en el
carbono central como no hay ningún
hidrógeno en este carbono entonces tiene
una carga formal positiva es un kart
vocación como el que vimos en los vídeos
anteriores un kart vocación está cargado
positivamente se siente atraído por
electrones entonces un campo catión
funciona como un electro filo una región
de baja densidad electrónica y ya hemos
dicho que en el etanol la parte del
oxígeno puede actuar como un núcleo filo
porque tiene una carga parcial negativa
tiene pares de electrones libres este
par de electrones puede atacar a este
carbono justo aquí las cargas opuestas
se atraen se formará un nuevo enlace
covalente
3 estas dos moléculas una vez más hemos
visto que los electrones se mueven desde
regiones de alta densidad electrónica es
decir desde un núcleo filo a regiones de
baja densidad electrónica al electro
filo es muy importante que lo entiendan
y esto me recuerda las reglas de swartz
5 cosas que hay que entender para tener
éxito en química orgánica
el doctor swartz un profesor fantástico
dijo que la química orgánica consta de
cinco cosas para poder entenderla la
primera son los electrones de valencia
espero que hayan visto lo importante es
que son siempre que dibujemos estos
mecanismos estamos dibujando los
electrones de valencia hay que tener la
habilidad para saber en dónde están los
electrones de valencia con cosas como la
carga formal y los estados de oxidación
son muy importantes el concepto de
electro negatividad también es muy
importante
es la segunda regla de swartz electro
negatividad hay que entender las
diferencias de electro negatividad y
cómo éstas afectan a las moléculas y
cómo afectan en las reacciones es muy
importante tercera los ácidos y bases
hay que entender los ácidos de bronce
lowry entender las bases de brondsted
laurie y poder seguir a los protones en
los mecanismos esa es la tercera regla
de swartz pasamos mucho tiempo en los
ácidos y bases y vimos la importancia de
eso cuando se hacen mecanismos la cuarta
regla de swartz son las reacciones redox
óxido reducción hay que asignar los
estados de oxidación encontrar cuál está
siendo oxidado y cuál es reducido y
finalmente la quinta regla de swartz es
el concepto de los núcleos y los hilos
electro filos si entienden estas cinco
cosas importantes pueden considerarse
buenos estudiantes de química orgánica
que la fuerza de swartz esté con ustedes